[Music]
they're from different corners of the
globe but there's a common adversary
that draws them together Iranian
president Ibrahim raisi arrived in
Havana Cuba on Thursday after wrapping
up visits to Venezuela and Nicaragua all
four countries share a strong hostility
towards the United States which has
long-running sanctions against them
former U.S President George Bush in fact
once labeled Iran and Cuba as members of
the quote axis of Evil
Tricia and his Cuban counterpart Miguel
bias canel held private talks before
their ministers signed a number of
cooperation agreements Cuba assisted
Iran during the pandemic by supplying
vaccines now Cuba is suffering from an
acute shortage of fuel which Iran may
help ease
we are grateful for your successful tour
of Latin America including Cuba
I see his first Latin American visit
since taking office nearly two years ago
aimed to underscore the need for
countries that do not fall under the U.S
fear of influence or friendship to stick
together they say it will lead to
further integration and the building of
a multi-polar world
the Iranian leader attended a business
forum and promised to work with Cuba in
hydroelectric power generation and
Mining
I have on my agenda the commitment I
made to the president I wanted to greet
you and confirm that the Islamic
Republic of Iran is determined to work
with friendly countries such as Cuba in
science and technology and for the
importance it has in our foreign policy
the U.S state department has been
watching the visit closely calling it
quote destabilizing Behavior
but while Iran may be very far away from
Latin America its choice of regional
allies shows that sharing a powerful
common adversary is a strong incentive
for sticking together
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera